Hello everybody, did you fucking know if you don't play if
you don't touch the game Fucking Arlo the horse takes over
as the main character like what the fuck?
I like I like booted up my game and I was like, oh, hey,
there's me sleeping and then suddenly the camera locks into
fucking Arlo I was like, what's they doing and he walks away
fuck since what the fuck is going on so i was just like
watching the horse i was literally just like watching the
horse just fucking walking away from my body and he just
runs around i'm just like where is he going where the fuck
is this horse going i was like i thought i was the main
character what the fuck is going on so like while i was just
waiting for this while i was like try to fix the stream um
because you know i actually almost started with 10 minute
delay because i was like why is the start stream not going
out like i was just like i was like why isn't the starting
screen like not not fucking like why is it not letting me
start the stream i was like oh the 10 minute delay oh um um
so yeah we're just gonna look see i'm the it's so I'm also
on the left side of the screen.
I know I know it's like really rare to see me on the left
side of the screen But I've had people on the last shadow
colossus being like I need to see the stamina bar Where's
the stamina bar doki?
Where the fuck is the stamina bar?
So then like you know, I decided to be like, you know what?
I'll be nice today I'll be nice today Today, I feel nice
today.
Okay, don't say I don't do nothing for you guys.
Okay, guys?
Don't say I don't do anything for you guys.
Because I, um, I, oh, he worked so hard to be on the left
screen, just so you guys know.
I, I worked so fucking hard.
It took so much courage and determination to, like, break
out of routine and, like, be on the left side.
So, if you say I don't do anything for you guys, that's a
fucking lie.
Now I'm on the left side of the screen.
Oh shit.
What happened to Arlo?
Oh it's nighttime.
I guess.
I guess now that it's nighttime.
They're like Arlo is like.
Never mind.
Um.
But yes.
Anyway.
A little update.
I know it's like.
It seems out of nowhere.
But I now have my create.
Okay.
Well I already.
had my creator code but just so you guys know this creator
code is actually the old creator code but i name changed it
to dokeybird so like now the old creator code doesn't work
anymore so you have to use dokeybird and i want to say like
a huge shout out to fortnite because like they actually like
uh was like it was a real i was talking to a real person by
the way like i i actually got to talk person and they like
helped me they were like oh we're gonna have to figure this
out today like slash tomorrow like you know tomorrow because
i contacted them on sunday and it's like it was like i don't
know 6 p.m on a sunday and then they're like um okay so
they're like okay we're gonna like try and see if we could
like get it fixed tomorrow when like the staff is there and
then i was like okay and then i received a message and
they're like oh we're actually can help you right with it
right now and then we had to like grab some stuff grab some
information um and then like uh and then they matched
actually i at first i was just like oh i just want like you
know just get my skins i don't care i don't care about
losing everything else please just give me my skin i was
like please i don't care about my fortnite skins bro please
i retail therapy so hard on fortnite because fortnite skins
was the only thing that made me happy back then and i bought
a john cena night skin and then i bought like basketball
dragon ball z cell skin please i bought so many dance emotes
please and then and then they're like oh you know what we
can't get you your entire epic account back we'll like help
you change the email i was like oh thank god i was just like
oh thank god i you know what i i came in here with super low
expectations because i thought i was not even able to get
back my account because everybody would tell me it was so
hard to get back your account and that like i just have to
be ready for them to say no because like my manager couldn't
like get in touch with anybody for two months i even asked
the twitch staff because they've done twitch rivals with
fortnite and they were like oh just so you know go in with
super low expectations man i don't know because i was like
can you reach out to fortnite for me and fortnite staff me
my account back and even twitch stat was like oh you have to
go in with super low expectations and then and then i put in
my last dish effort public pressure
because because if it can work out for youtube maybe it can
work on 49 if nothing else works public pressure is my last
ditch effort I I'm not I'm not ashamed I'm not ashamed I I
was desperate guys so thank you everybody for signal
boosting I was so fucking desperate I really I really wanted
my account back so thank you guys for for helping out and
helping me signal boost so that fortnight saw the tweet and
they like personally dm me and was like hey we can help you
out i was like oh my god a real person i was like i was like
oh my god a real person wants to help me out
bro even even twitch was like bro i don't know man
even twitch was like i don't this is what happened are those
going on his own adventure again because at first i was like
there's me i was like wait why is the camera moving away
from me what is going on what the fuck is it why is the
camera moving away that's not me and then he um but yeah
that is the story of how i got my fortnite account back so
for those who were like uh for those who are like what does
the creator code do basically it's basically like uh when
you go to the shop uh there's like support a creator and you
just copy and paste on fortnite and then you just paste
dokeybird and basically it's like i every purchase you make
in the shop whether you're buying vbucks or like you're buy
like whether you're buying like any item in the shop i get
what the percent was.
I think it was like 5% or was it was like 5% I remember like
back then I made a joke be as people were like saying no
Doki you have a problem with fortnight skins but like the
first month of fortnight the first month my creator creator
code came out I got 2,500 and that was 5% of whatever the
fuck you guys were purchasing so like in the end I don't
have a problem
If I get 5% and I end up getting 2,500 in the first month
from people using my creator code, I'm not the one with the
problem.
So, we all, we all as a group have issues.
all of us have issues it's not just me because I got 5% and
that 5% was 2,500 so somebody some of you dragons have more
of a problem than me someone calculate how many vbucks how
many dollars worth of vbucks was that something
You guys can't judge me on my spending issues Yeah, what the
hell yeah, you guys can't judge me anymore when it comes to
my spending Anyway, I'm glad there's no 10-minute delay
because I accidentally almost spent have a have like
10-minute delay there All right today.
We're gonna re oh, I also forgot how to play this game game
because like uh i forgot to play this game because it's been
a while we were able to play it last week so you guys are
gonna help me with remembering this all right arlo this is
my time you're not the main character anymore continue oh i
got to defeated five colossi we colossi oh yeah colossi is
the plural of colossus whoops all right i'll play this game
again it's not an issue i I could stop whatever I want.
Affiliate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay.
This is the hitting button.
Okay, and then... Why is my camera so wonky right now?
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
That's Arlo.
Alright, where is it?
Where is it?
This way?
Alright, we have to go this way.
Alright, Arlo.
It's back to figuring how to control this camera.
All right, five down.
Okay, wait.
Where is it?
This way.
All right, here we go.
How do I?
Wait, I can stand up?
Wait, why would I need to stand up?
How did I do that?
How did I?
What?
Stand back up.
Okay, now I can stand.
Why would I need to stand on the horse?
I don't understand to jump.
Oh.
Oh, that is not going to be fun.
That is not going to be fun when I actually have to do that.
Okay, how do I ride this horse?
Okay.
Alright.
How do I...
Guys, I'm trying to remember how to ride this horse.
Okay, triangle.
Alright, it's triangle.
Okay.
Okay, where do we have to go?
Oh, God.
I remember now why I hated this.
I hated the horse riding mechanic.
I remember now.
i remember now i hated it chat all right let's try and
remember all right how many 11 right we have 11 to go all
right don't worry this is gaming hours right here at the
moment look even though even though like um i'm very
forgetful and that like uh and like it takes me a while to
figure out the mechanics but the moment i figure it out i go
i'm full gamer you can't deny that chat the moment i figure
out the mechanics even though like you know i'm a little
slow with figuring stuff out i start gaming okay okay guys
just so you remember i start gaming the moment i realize
what the mechanics are all right do you have to go up the
fuck is it it's like here app.
All right.
Is it like, do I get to climb this?
Let's see.
Or do I go around it?
Do I go around this?
Maybe?
Is there an around?
Or maybe I can climb.
You know what?
Maybe I can climb this.
Okay, wait.
Does the fruit do anything?
There's fruit here?
Can I eat that?
Can I eat the fruit?
All right, let's see.
How do I...
Okay, I'm crouching.
All right, let's see if I can eat the fruit.
Oh, I can eat the fruit!
Can I?
Guys, I don't know if I pick up.
Pick up the fruit.
Oh, okay.
Wait, how do I eat it?
Eat the fruit.
Guys, I ate the fruit.
Guys, I figured it out, chap.
It was R2.
See, I told you guys.
The moment I figure out the mechanics, I start gaming.
Oh, wait, there's more.
Okay, there's more.
I told you guys.
Camera, please.
The moment I figure this out, I start gaming.
Okay, this is, like, not fair.
I actually have to preach.
Okay, this is not fair because I literally can't see it on
the camera.
look at that gaming this is called fps pure fps skills right
there prediction time actual gaming right there all right
not to remember how to climb okay okay time i can't climb
this guys apparently i can't climb this all right all right
all right we got figure out how to get to the other colossi
all right sorry pure tps right there all right now we have
more hp i feel like maybe we can go around from here right
oh no i wish there was a lost emotes maybe here it has to be
here is that an indent in the wall No, it's just a wall.
It's just a fucking wall.
Oh, no.
This is the worst part.
It's the other way.
Okay, I'm going back.
All right, we're figuring this out.
Guys, we're going to figure this out.
Go, Arlo.
Go, go.
Go, Arlo, go.
Hey, like, at least I'm eating and drinking water, right?
My guy is actually eating and drinking water.
So, like, you know, things are not bad.
You know?
You're staying hydrated and, like, you stay hydrated and,
like, surviving.
Okay.
This way.
Go, Arlo.
Go.
Please.
It's really hard to open an acupuncture massage parlor in
this neighborhood.
We get, like, one client every, like, couple of months.
Don't worry.
My dead girlfriend will appreciate this for sure.
Do I go up?
Let's see.
Oh, no, that's not the sword.
I wish I had a magical bow.
It sucks.
Why did the devil only bless my fucking sword and not my
bow?
Like, if they can bless more than one thing, like, if they
can bless one thing, they might as well bless the other.
You know?
You need magical arrows?
I'll just come and pick it up.
It's not like I shot it pretty far.
If it's magical, it'll be glowing.
Please, Arlo, just walk around the trees.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, this is...
Oh, no.
I don't like this.
Where am I?
Magic sword!
Okay, this way.
Alright.
There.
Look.
They can bless like...
Please.
Okay, I'm getting off.
I'm getting off.
I was pissing me.
I'm not lost yet.
I have the sun.
I have the power of the sun.
Wait, maybe it's down here.
It has to be, right?
Like, why would there be a cave?
Okay.
Nice.
Boon the Nomad.
What?
Where?
here I got an achievement can I steal your stuff what oh is
this an Easter egg I can't steal anything why can't I steal
anything what's the point of having an Easter egg if I can't
steal uh oh wait wait oh what the did i pick up that's it
who is that the did i pick up what do i do with that it just
exists it just what was that what was that okay oh well it
just exists in my pocket now i don't know what i received
but it just on me for some reason.
Alright.
Time to figure out where to go.
Sword.
Oh no.
Where the fuck's the sun?
All the trees are blocking the sun.
This way.
Okay.
It's this way.
Do I just jump down?
Is this it?
Oh this is it.
That'll be fine.
Watch this.
this guys i don't know why he's hesitating
hmm i have a feeling i shouldn't jump down
do you guys think i can like catch one of the rocks down
there i don't think
Okay, okay, I actually don't- guys, I'm not gonna do it
because I need to find a shrine first.
I- I don't want to- I don't want to shoot the things again.
Man, I wonder why the main character was hesitating just
now.
I wonder why.
I think that's the road down, right?
This has to be the road down.
Okay.
Oh, where's the sun?
Oh, this fucking tiny piece of shade blocked it.
It has to be here.
How do I get down from there?
Okay, I'm just...
That shouldn't kill me, right?
I don't...
I like how the main character was like, no.
The main character is just like, please, please, Doki, don't
do it.
Surely...
That was...
Arna, why are you running ahead?
Look, I'm trying to...
I'm testing the limits.
I'm trying to, like, test the limits of, like, fall damage.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
The horse riding mechanic has to be, like, the hardest
mechanic.
Wait, what's this over there?
What's that over there?
There's, like, a little hole.
What is that?
Is that the way down?
Oh, it was!
I missed the hole.
Whoops.
Did I?
Did I miss the hole?
Oh my god.
This is just a tiny shade.
What do you mean?
I can't fucking see anything.
Alright.
This has to be the place.
This has to be the area.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is the shade?
Where's the sun?
Oh my god.
Oh the clouds are blocking the sun.
How am I gonna find out where to go?
Is this the area was it here was i looking at here oh it's
this way wait is this not the area oh my god i'm just what
did i like activate something the game was like no i can't
even jump over here it was like no uh-uh no cheesy
I like how the game was like no no no donkey no cheese thing
this I am looking at the map what you mean I'm looking at it
right now it's so hard to be a traveling acupuncture
specialist it really is I need like stop allowing like home
visits I guess I really need to like like stop allowing home
visits for like for like acupuncture and massages i really
need to stop that oh wait is this sand is it is it a sand a
sand colossus where is it okay it's this way all right all
right i don't know i don't trust like i don't know i feel
like when you're like a specialist that just travels to like
travels to people's homes for your thing.
It's so risky.
What if you get murdered?
Like, that sounds so fucking risky.
You don't know where they can't come from.
You know where they really come from.
I love sand.
I hate sand.
This has to be it.
This is it?
That's just a...
That's just a rock.
Where the fuck does this guy live?
Where the fuck do you live?
Sir?
Here?
Underground?
Where the fuck is here?
Oh, oh, here, here.
Okay, get off.
Alright, here you go.
He has to live here.
There's no other way.
It has to live here.
Has to be here.
Alright, I figured it out.
He's underneath.
He's underground.
Wait, crouch?
Crouch?
I know you can crouch.
Oh, that's all.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently, I don't know how to crouch.
I was wrong.
He definitely did not.
know how to crouch.
Wee.
Alright.
Time to go to my next appointment.
Hello, sir.
Your acupuncture specialist is here.
Don't worry.
My rates are very reasonable.
I'll be five out of five stars on Yelp.
I would die if I...
Oh, my God.
No!
Why didn't they stop me?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we're gonna...
Oh, my God.
Oh, whoa!
Yay!
Okay, I actually thought I was gonna die.
I actually thought I was gonna die.
Thank God.
Thank God, walls.
The walls saved my life.
Alright, what do you look like?
Don't worry, sir.
Where does it... Where is all your stress?
Oh my god, he big.
Is that a gorilla?
Of a beard?
Is it monkey?
Oh, it's the brother?
Your brother's not...
Your brother is so fucking alive.
live sir okay where do i oh do i go here where are these
where are these fucking walls oh yep all right all right i'm
sorry i'm so sorry oh my god oh my god how did you walk that
fast you were so Wow!
You just jumped like two miles away from me!
How did I get hurt?
Like what?
All right, here I go.
Here I go.
I don't know how he's suddenly so fucking fast, but here I
go.
Wee!
Okay.
Okay, now I don't know.
Now I don't know.
What do I do?
Oh!
I'm like a little rat.
Hello, sir.
Hello, please.
Your brother really liked it.
He's totally very much alive.
He just didn't call you because he's just so fucking
relaxed.
Okay?
He just didn't call you because he was just so relaxed, sir.
What's it do?
Hit me?
Look at him.
He doesn't know what to do.
He's just looking at me.
What's he got to do?
Just walking around.
Hello.
Yay.
I don't know.
Is he gonna come closer?
Hello?
Oh!
We'll grab your beard!
Ah!
There we go.
Sir, you need to trim your fucking beard, sir.
I actually have no idea where the weak point is.
I did not pay it.
Oh, it's on the head.
It's always on the head because you're always stressed in
the head.
Don't worry!
I'm here!
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
The specialist is here.
I need a revival!
Oh, oh my god.
Please do not resist!
Do not resist, sir!
It is for- do you want to live long?
If you want to live long and prosper, you gotta take this!
Boom, there you go.
I really, I need to, like, chill a little bit.
No word, that's just the oil.
It's called stress oil.
Trust the process.
It's not blood.
It might look like blood.
But it's just all the excess oil in your head.
Because you're thinking too much, sir.
You are just thinking too much.
All right, there you go.
I need to figure out where the other one is
Okay, I'm gonna go to the okay.
Do you figure out where the other one is?
Don't worry.
I'm a fucking licensed professional.
I got my license online That's when you know I'm
professional
I'm going to assume it's the back I'm gonna assume Like all
toxic.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Please.
Okay, I'm gonna assume it's back here.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
Only a professional would know this.
I fucking knew it.
Don't worry.
A licensed professional knows where all the toxic is.
Okay.
Oh, no, fuck.
Okay, this is gonna be bad.
This is gonna be bad.
Please stop shaking, sir.
Please stop shaking.
You have, like, I can feel the toxic energy right here.
You have really bad back acne, sir.
Don't worry.
I think the hardest part was literally trying to find your
house, sir.
Like, you need a better address, man.
Like, you need a mailbox outside.
How would people deliver your mail?
Please look at all these stress juice
There we go, we did it Look at all that oil coming out of
his body Let the impurities yes, it's the black acne Okay, I
don't know if it's like an Asian parents thing, but like I
know that oh god, sorry the black act um it's got me so like
you i don't know if this is an ancient parents thing or just
a regular parents thing but like when you're growing up your
mom would my mom would always like talk about the what is it
called the like the black oil on your nose and stuff and
like the like she would like try to squeeze the she would
like be like no you have there's so much black oil on your
nose and she always gives me like these things to put yeah
the blackhead yeah yeah my mom would always talk about the
blackheads and stuff on my nose and like when i get them
she's like no you have to fucking squeeze it i'm like okay i
don't think i don't think squeezing is the right thing to do
it's actually bad yeah i was like and then later on in life
i was like oh my god wait you be squeezing squeezing is
actually really bad for your fucking skin who would have
died
i did it another happy customer
a fucking those like fucking tape stuff for your nose you
get like blackheads don't worry i'm here to squeeze the
giant's nose for their blackhead treatment all right yeah i
could leave scars yeah i wish little doky-no but i don't
have scars on my nose by the way i don't have scars on my
nose but it definitely did not help my skin it definitely it
definitely did not my skin by squeezing the black the
blackheads out all right it's time to save pray to save yay
another happy customer pray to save pray pray nice all right
where's the other one okay oh my god is it the sand time
okay no it's not sand time because it's in the opposite
direction never mind it's not sand time because it's in the
opposite direction all right here also don't know how to
fucking turn on this horse it's lake time it's lake time
thought it's sand time you guys were like the sand snake
okay this way I just have to go straight straight time yeah
All right, here you go.
It's this way.
Is this the lake?
Oh my god, do you remember the lake?
Hey, Arlo, do you remember?
Do you remember the happy times we had in that?
All right, we have to figure out how to get down.
I actually don't remember how to get down from the lake.
Uh...
How do I get down from here?
How the fuck?
Where the fuck is the ladder?
Where is the ladder?
Is it through this bridge?
Just... Guys, no.
I know we can't just jump.
We've...
We've tested that theory before.
Is that bridge?
Is that a bridge?
No, that's not a bridge.
Can't tell.
It's just fucking...
There.
Oh, it's the wrong way.
Okay.
God, I'm so directionless.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I was born in a time when GPS exists.
Like, thank god.
Please!
Arlo!
Turn around!
There you go.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm happy.
I know people are like, would you rather be born like, uh,
like 50 years ago or like, uh, in the past or 50 years in
the future?
I think I like where I'm currently at.
Maybe, like, a little bit.
Maybe I wish I was born, like, a little bit.
Um...
Did I just go back the same way?
No.
No?
Oh, fucking...
We'll figure it out later.
I don't think I did, right?
I don't know if... Did I just went back the same way?
I can't tell.
It's under.
It's like the lake is below me.
I know the lake.
This is the lake.
Yeah, this is the lake.
Is this a lake or is this an ocean?
I'll never know.
This has to be the lake.
Okay.
I do sometimes wish.
Wait, no.
Wait, is this a lake or an ocean?
This is an ocean.
There's a lake?
It's all water!
How am I supposed to tell?
they're all the same it's just what oh my god i have i don't
think i'm meant to ride horses please please yeah i'm
definitely not meant to ride horses but you know how the
people okay this is not the right way people are like oh
would you rather be born 50 years ahead i wish i was born
maybe like uh maybe like 10 years maybe like five years in
advance because like I was uh so then I can like be more of
a I can be like full-on zoomer but with like but with like
uh uh with like more FPS skills
sorry so I could grow up longer playing video games
is this a lake The sword keeps pointing down.
How the fuck do I go down?
Is that a lake?
Or is it the lake behind me?
No, because I've been there.
That's where I killed the other colossus.
Okay.
Lake.
Follow the path?
The path is...
is down.
But then I already been to that Colossus.
Where the fuck's the lake?
Because like, I was there already.
Alright, I guess we'll do this again?
I hate going over here, because there's no fucking light.
There's like no light at all here.
So I actually have to rely on pure instinct, and I don't
have that.
Also, I don't want to be born, like, Like back.
I might be born ahead, but not too ahead because I'm scared
of global Not too ahead because I think we sort of fucked up
the planet.
I'm not sure yet though And I don't want to I don't want to
be born too ahead to find out
Yeah, I I don't want to like find out if I think we said I
don't know I don't know judging by the what the weather is
like currently I don't know also if I was born too far but
too far back in the past there's no there's no internet and
I don't know how to survive well to be fair if I didn't grow
up with the internet I wouldn't have to worry about like not
knowing how to survive without it but like oh my god I'd
have to get a if it weren't for the internet I'd have to get
a real job
where you going try to fucking figure out if this is the
lake is this the lake are you a lake sir there's no way
because I killed a colossi up here
where's the There's so many bodies of water.
Is this lake?
We're muster.
Muster where?
Keep going.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Arlo, get over here.
Arlo.
I go this way?
It's further north.
I don't know.
Am I going north?
Guys, there's no compass.
Am I...
Oh my god, where's my phone app to tell me where I am?
Where's my...
Bro, I'll even take Apple Maps at this point.
That's how desperate I am.
I'm so desperate.
I'll even use Apple Maps.
You have a map...
Does this map look fucking...
Like, does this map look like it's readable?
It doesn't tell me where Lake is.
There's no...
my gps doesn't even work this is a shitty gps because i
require the sun it's a solar powered sword like
it's literally a solar powered sword i don't know what to
tell you okay all right solar power where am i where the
fuck am i lake are you lake yeah okay wait there's a sun
over here oh my god there's a sun okay lake time okay sword
tell me where to go
this way okay this way all right i figured it out my sword
my solar power gps tells me to go this way oh my god
reception here is fucking terrible everything i do for my
dead girlfriend okay Okay, she better not fucking cheat on
me after saving her fucking life.
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God.
If she leaves me, if she fucking leaves me after I killed 15
colossi's for her, I swear to fucking God.
I'm going through so much just to fucking save her life.
okay no no gps my where am i where the am i there's no water
anywhere where am i where am i hey oh god i'm so lost what
the fuck is this i don't know do you know where lake is
maybe this way this way seems like a lakey area this is this
this this is a it's just this is a lakey area bro I'm
desperate I'm using my legs this is how desperate I am I'm
actually using my fucking legs oh my god someone give me the
fucking sun.
Lake, where are you?
Where's water?
Why is there so many lakes here?
We gotta industrialize this area.
We gotta make this a city so I don't have to deal with all
these lakes.
Is that shrine?
No, those are just rocks.
Where's the sun?
Where the fuck's the sun?
I think I'm going the right area?
Alright, I'm gonna trust you on this boy.
I'm gonna trust you.
I'm gonna follow my heart.
My heart tells me that this is where the lake is.
If there's no lake here, I'm gonna make my own fucking lake.
Is this another area?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Me down this path, there's a lake.
Okay.
Maybe down this path, there's the lake I'm looking for.
And then, or the sun, you know, I'll take either.
I'll take the fucking GPS.
My solar-powered GPS.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Solar-powered GPS.
Boor-do.
But...
Guys, how the fuck do I get over there?
Did I go the wrong way?
Did I...
Did I go...
No, I must not have.
No, this has to be the right way.
There's no...
How do I get over to the other side?
There's no way...
No.
There's no way.
This has to be.
There's no other path.
That's literally the only path I have.
It's heading...
Wait, it's heading further and further away from where my
sword was gonna ask me to go, but like it has to be It has
to like miraculously turn right Like please
Oh my god, please please it has to miraculously turn right
Oh no, where am I?
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Riding a horse, don't turn the sticks.
He travels automatic through these paths.
Oh, he does!
Wait, does he?
Oh, my God!
He moves on his own!
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Everything changed.
This entire game changed for me.
I literally don't have to move.
He can move for me.
Guys, I think I went the wrong way, guys.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure I went the wrong way.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm heading to a new path.
I'm going to a new area.
Oh, wait, I'm going up.
This might be where the lake is.
Oh, my God.
Arlo knows where to go.
Okay, GPS.
Where do I go, GPS?
Where do I fucking go?
Did I go the wrong way?
Do I...
Is it like maybe...
Okay, or the...
Here?
Okay, guys, guys.
Right or forward?
Maybe...
Maybe the lake is a sky lake.
Guys, maybe...
guys which way guys which way right or left
guys right or left guys this is left and this is right left
okay okay guys maybe it's a sky lake guys maybe maybe maybe
the lake is in the sky you don't know that all right this
has to be the lake there's no other explanation there's no
other explanation this has to be where the lake is right no
right there's no way Arlo knows Arlo you know right I trust
in him I trust in this GPS powers okay let's just you guys
you Guys
Bruh I guess I don't think I don't think I'm at the right
path I I for some reason I have a feeling I'm definitely I'm
definitely not going the right way I don't know I don't
know.
Oh wait unless unless I wait wait i know oh my god unless
this is a lake wait i think i've
guys i knew it you have to go up to go down this is it i'm
fucking oh i got shrine too this is it i found the i found
the shrine i knew this is almost like a lake okay have i
been here i've been to the shrine before this is the first
time prayed.
No, wait.
Wait, no, I've been to the shrine before.
No, this is one of the two shrines I've been to.
Oh my god!
I've been here before!
Oh my god.
Guys, I've been to the shrine before.
Alright.
Okay.
It's okay.
But this has to be where the lake is now.
Alright, the lake...
lake is this way.
This has to be the lake.
There's no... How do I get over this?
It has to be over this platform.
Alright.
Beyond the shrine.
So down here.
Okay.
Just keep going.
Alright.
This is...
This has... Wait.
Did I come from here?
Wait.
Did I... No.
No I didn't.
Okay.
Wait can I climb that?
Oh, I can?
Alright.
Okay, I can climb it.
Okay.
Alright, this is it.
This is it.
I figured it out.
I did not look at chat.
I figured it out with my own fucking intuition.
This is it.
I figured it out, Arlo.
With my own intuition.
Okay, how do I get up?
Jump.
can't climb this i can't fucking
guys who the fuck said i could climb this guys guys guys i
lied i read chat in the chat fucking lied i did not get two
guys i did not get one guy i did not get two guys I get like
several guide.
I fucking saw like four different people that told me to
climb this.
I literally saw four different people that said you should
climb it.
And I was like, oh my god, I figured it out.
Where's Arlo going?
Hello, where are you going?
I need you to go this path.
Okay, maybe it's this way, right?
Where did I come from again?
I came from the top, so it has to be...
Wait.
where did I come from?
Where did I...
Here.
I did not come from here.
Yeah.
Here.
Alright, this is where I didn't come from.
So the lake...
The lake should be down there.
Should be left side.
Because that's where the thing is.
Right?
It should be left.
This is where the lake should be oh my god i'm so this this
has to be where the lake is because the thing was like go
left oh no where's the gps telling me no i'm going back in
the same area i'm going i'm going around again no where's my
gps oh go right okay I go right okay this way all right I
turned around I apparently the last time I went left now I
go right this is where lake is lake how do you guys remember
where the fuck the lake is sleepy I left for a meeting are
we still looking for the lake Sleepy, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you.
Wait, now it's sand.
Why sand?
Sand eventually leads the lake.
Guys, if you guys didn't know, sand becomes water.
Because that's where sand comes from.
Sand comes from, like, the, like, erosion of rock.
From water.
This is where lake is.
Right?
Lake?
Where is this?
Is this the lake?
Where the fuck do I get down?
This is lake!
Oh my god, this is lake.
We made it.
Wait, I told you.
I told...
I told you.
Sad eventually becomes water.
by pure science I fucking knew it I swear like majority of
this gameplay it's just me trying to figure out where the
fuck things are alright okay I thought I was gonna die from
that how much oh my god I love fuck okay okay not jumping
anymore I lost a lot of HP from that unless Whoa, that's
fucking right.
I'm gaming.
Where is he?
Panzer, thank you for the 20 ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Here we go.
Oh, he's fish.
Wait, electric fish.
Does it hurt?
I wonder if I touch...
Man, I wonder if I touch the electricity in the water.
Will it hurt?
It's time to find out.
out fuck around and find out please don't fuck around and
find out please don't all right here i go time to touch the
touch the fish time to touch the fish sir can i touch you
remember to ask permission sir i am here for the appointment
sir do not worry i am a Sir, it's not gonna hurt.
It's not gonna hurt when I give you your acupuncture, sir.
It's all about getting rid of that tox, the dirty toxins in
your body.
How do I fucking piss him off?
Come on, come up.
Look on the water.
What the fuck?
Not like that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where's the part?
Where's the part where it doesn't do it?
that oh what no i missed out i'm so confused i missed out i
hear you don't worry i figured it out i i didn't know the
tail i i didn't know i was like just the fucking i didn't
know i was just out of reach from the tail to be fair oh my
god i can't even get up on this where does he go back up to
breathe the air apparently Are you like a shark?
Or are you going to go back up to breathe air?
Is it a...
You're not a fish.
You're a fake fish.
If you need to come back up for water, you're a fucking fake
fish.
Broko, thank you for the gift of ship.
Thank you.
You need to come back to the service.
You ain't a fucking real fish.
You're a fucking lie to society.
Alright.
Where is he?
swimming too.
Where are you swimming too?
Where the fuck is that?
How the fuck do I get there?
Like, oh my god.
Bro, how the fuck...
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
This is it.
This has to be the tail.
Tail, tail, tail, tail, tail.
Go up.
Nice.
That's what!
It still didn't even go up.
Yeah, I was thinking about dolphins.
I am trying my best.
He barely goes back up for water.
Ow.
Oh, oh, oh.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
What do I do?
I'm not even on the right side of history right now.
Wait, where am I?
Like, where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, there I am.
How do I...
How do I... I'm so...
Please, please head back up.
Please... I'm trying!
I'm trying to cry!
Oh, okay, here you go.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, no.
Grab on, grab on.
Grab on, grab on, grab on.
Alright.
Silly dokey, you're always on the right side.
Ah!
Okay, okay, we're fine.
Okay, we're fine.
There we go.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, I can feel the stress on this muscle too.
Look at all the stress juice.
The more stress truce there is, the more you know I'm
helping.
Oh, it's already disabled, bro.
I didn't know that.
I was saying.
Whoa.
Let me climb up here.
Overkill, dokey.
It's a stress truce.
You never heard of it?
Guys, whenever you're super stressed out and you poke, like,
deep enough, All the stress juice comes out.
Oh, no.
No!
Okay.
No.
No, I'm drowning.
Wait, I'm actually drowning.
I forgot I have to breathe.
Guys, did you know humans cannot breathe underwater?
Did you guys know that?
Fun fact.
We were not met in...
fact guys our lungs are not built to breathe underwater is
that so fun what no way i know it's this game just taught me
that humans can't breathe underwater science brought to you
by dokeybird mama shiba god i love mama shiba i used to
watch that shit i didn't like me like when i was little i
made a fucking like digital wallpaper of mama shiba and i
posted it on tumblr
Yeah, ow.
Yeah, that was me.
Where's the tail?
Grab.
Alright.
I grabbed.
I love Mama Shiba.
It's actually one of my favorite.
One of my favorite, like, animated shorts ever.
I learned so many fun facts.
It's how I became so fun.
That's why I'm so fun.
fun, guys.
I know all these fun facts.
I just...
Nope, I can't.
I can't let go.
I need to wait until I resurface, and then I can like run.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Bro, this sucks.
I have to get closer.
Come on, just head up.
Get over there.
The Doki Special.
The Doki Special is coming!
Okay.
This has to be it.
Bro, that was like a tiny-ass poke.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god, you gotta lay off on the electricity, man!
It's all the fucking electricity!
You're just getting more and more stressed out!
Oh, I just...
Oh, I disabled the electricity!
Bro!
It's because of all the electricity causing all the stress
juice to build up.
you gotta relax bro it's not good for you don't worry I have
a home remedy guys guys I'm one HP
guys I don't think he likes my home remedies guys I don't
think I didn't think he liked that bad i'm like one hp right
now oh oh don't worry i can like heal right don't worry what
hp ain't so bad just don't get hit of course just don't get
hit do i can i like heal if i was just wait wait wait wait
do i can Can I heal if I just, like, stand on somewhere?
Is it because I'm swimming that I'm not self-healing?
Alright, let's see.
I'm just gonna stand over there.
Alright.
Don't worry, sir.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Am I self-healing?
Why the fuck are you tired?
Why are you tired?
You little bitch?
You're not like...
allowed to be tired.
It's all about satisfying the customer's demands.
Then you can go home back to your one, back to your studio
apartment.
The customer is always right.
Look.
Oh, I have to crouch.
Oh, crouch to heal faster.
Oh, so smart.
Welcome to the service industry.
Bro, this is getting too real.
This is the life we sign up for.
Come back up.
Come back up so I can grab your tail.
Sir, can I still grab your tail?
Sir, look at you.
I can see...
Oh my god, I can feel the stress aura from your fucking
body.
From my home.
Don't worry, you just need a crystal.
Can I recommend you a crystal for you to purchase?
Where the fuck is the tail?
I missed.
Guys, there was the tail.
Can I recommend you some crystal healing?
Queen, thank you for the supercharge.
Thank you, thank you, doctor.
I want to cancel my appointment.
Here's the refund.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry.
I can grab on the second.
No, he's just being shy.
He's just being shy because I'm, like, streaming my
sessions.
Like, those people that stream their actual job, like, the,
like, those, like, convenience stores.
And, like, um, like, those convenience stores and stuff
where, where they stream their jobs and stuff.
Sir!
I know like it wasn't in the fine print when you fucking
bought my services but like there's a lot there I have I
have to also look I have bills to pay I have bills to pay
all right and I need the content so like I'm here to I'm
here to stream this acupuncture session you're violating
patient confidentiality look to violate doctor patient
confidentiality that I actually have to be licensed.
Which I totally am.
Which I am, chat.
Which is totally true.
Alright, this has to be the tail.
Did I grab onto it?
Look, nice.
Alright, I grabbed the tail.
I firmly grasped the tail.
I totally am licensed, guys.
It's not like I learned from online YouTube videos.
But to be like you know um it doesn't hurt like a youtube a
person who learns from youtube video is just as valid as a
person who learned professionally at school they are just
the same this is only my this is like you know my opinion as
someone who got my degree professionally who licensed
professionally but like I think personally self-taught
people are just oh my god okay give me a second I personally
think people who are self-taught are just as valid please
let me get closer please okay there you go I'll take it I'll
take it for the content you There you go.
There you go.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God I got the head.
Alright.
Come on, get back up.
Get back up there.
Woo!
Boom!
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Thank God I finally got through the head.
Look, look at that.
I got rid of all your electricity.
When you get really stressed out, like, lightning starts
coming out.
Alright, here you go.
Come on, please!
Sir!
I charge you by the hour!
It looks really fucking cool.
Yeah, he does.
All right, there you go.
Bye-bye.
Oh, God.
Come on!
Let me fucking poke you!
Yes.
You can see I've already helped him so much, you know,
because he's not- he doesn't have electricity anymore.
Oh, I did it.
Yay.
Anyway, unrelated to this, but we're having fish for dinner.
I also made, like, a little blowhole for them.
So, like, they don't have to always, like, come up all the
time up in the air for, like, you know, to breathe.
They just need to poke their little blowhole.
I self-made a blowhole for them.
happy customer what a happy fish so happy so considerate I
know unrelated to this but dragoons I got you guys fish for
dinner totally not dead by the way of course not he's not
dead he's so relaxed that he fell asleep deep in the ocean
That's how fish asleep.
It didn't float up.
I got you guys.
Guys.
Did it float up?
No.
If it was dead, it would float up.
It did not float up.
So in the end, it is still alive.
Who's the specialist here?
Who is the license?
Not self-taught.
massage parlor owner here look at all my happy customers
surrounding me if they were not happy they would not be
surrounding me with surrounding me and giving me glowing
reviews happy is such a strong word what if I don't want to
look at it I don't want to look at God nope gonna look away
the forest oh the floor is colossi who's
my next happy customer where's
the license okay you guys want to see my license okay give
me a second okay fine you guys don't believe me guys okay
okay let me show you guys my my license real quick let me
let me show you guys look before we Because I have some
fucking doubters right now in my chat.
So I'm here to prove you guys wrong.
That I have a license to be a massage parlor owner.
To like do acupuncture.
Alright look.
It's called.
You guys might not know this.
But I am licensed.
Sorry for speaking so slow.
Because like today I feel extra stupid.
and then oh I found and then okay so I found my photo ID too
so here it is and uh wait give me a sec give me a sec sorry
it's so hard to find it because it's like there's like so
many files in my pc so I'm still trying to find it you know
I'm still I'm still trying to find it so it's it's really
hard to find it because you know my file there's just so
many files in there uh but don't worry don't worry i think
oh wait wait i found it okay i think i found it okay give me
a sec guys give me a sec guys it exists by the way it 100
exist i just need a i just need it to like you know um oh
it's on Wrong file type, guys.
It's on the wrong file type, so I need to I need to, like,
convert it to the right file type.
Give me a sec, everybody.
I'm just, I'm just converting my, I'm converting it to the
right file type real quick.
And then, alright, here you go.
Okay, and then alright, okay, it's in, like, W-E-B-M-P.
I don't know why I saved it as a W-E-M-B-P.
But, but like, oh my god, you guys are gonna regret this.
You're
Yes, you guys are gonna regret saying I don't have a
license.
You're gonna regret it.
License.
That earned from, like, massage school.
You're gonna regret it.
I earned this in massage school.
Okay, and then, uh...
Give me a sec.
Guys, okay, found it.
I found it.
I found the ID.
chat oh my god you're so i found the id chat give me a sec
give me a sec i need a i need to pin my id onto my shirt so
you guys will know every time when you see it that you'll
know that that is a 100 real id right there right what that
look i even scanned it i found my id and i even scanned it
So you guys would know.
That's how dedicated I am.
I even scanned my ID to my PC.
Because it was a hard copy license.
If you are a licensed massage parlor owner.
Like you would know that you have to like.
Have a physical copy of your license at all times.
There you go.
Wait you can't really see.
see it.
You can't really see it.
There.
There you go.
So real.
It's so real.
I got it at like massage school.
No, it's real.
I scanned it.
I scanned this fucking license.
How can you say this is not real?
I don't understand.
And so, it even has a photo ID.
So, people can't impersonate me.
Like, so, so people can impersonate me.
How can you guys say that?
Bro, I can't believe it.
I'm going to put this like...
This is my face now.
It's on the back of the card.
Everybody knows the license number is...
For those who are like, oh, where's the license number?
We all...
Real massage owners knows that the license number is on the
back of the card.
You guys are just fucking jealous you didn't complete
massage school.
You're jealous.
You don't have a thriving massage business like me.
Look at that.
y'all fucking jealous there's some strong paper attorney
badge thank you thank you for the super chat johnny thank
you thank you okay here you are now you know now you guys
will always know that i have a list legit license to massage
here's my name kit tag right here i'm like certified Why is
the spell?
That's a Canadian way of spelling license!
I'm sorry!
Why is license spelled like that?
It's the Canadian spelling of license!
It's like British English, but Canadian English.
My Canadians would vouch for me.
It's a Canadian way.
You guys don't understand because you're not Canadian.
You're not part of the...
Canada too for people who are like oh I'm in Canada but we
don't spell it like that yeah but that's the west coast of
Canada way of spelling license you don't know that because
you're not in the west coast you're like you must be an
Eastie I bet you're an Eastie man yeah I'm Canadian yeah
Breeze I bet you're an Eastie you're not a Westie It's the
Canadian...
It's a West Coast Canadian way of spelling.
License.
Alright, here you go.
Let's go.
You just don't understand.
You didn't grow up where I grew up.
You guys don't understand.
By the way, I know it's been like an hour into the game, but
I hope the volume's been okay.
I know it's might be a bit too late to ask but I hope the
volume's been okay throughout it so far as a true maple
syrup drinker that is a proper yeah see I knew it I knew it
whoops whoops sorry I fucking knew I was right I knew it
shout out to a bag bro I don't even have to click it shout
out to bag for the super chat the very first super chat too
his very first super chat on the channel and and the fee fee
like fucking endorses what i say as a true maple syrup
drinker that is a proper massage parlor license yeah i knew
i knew i was right i fucking knew i should want to raise the
music just a little bit I'll raise it a little bit I fucking
knew it I knew I was correct okay this way paid actor he is
not paid alright this way where am I supposed to go I can't
believe I live so far way far west again I now live in
Quebec crazy thank you for the super chap thank you day I
bet you're Quebec
Spoken like a true Kippekwa
Nice try, Doki, but you forgot one vital point Canada is not
real, D-Dragon Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank
you That's why I'm a YouTuber Not real Just like women I
fucking knew it Canada and women weren't real I fucking knew
it I knew it all along Okay, I need to like fucking figure
out where to go It has to be this way, right?
Alright Okay If you're Canadian and you are Trying to say
I'm not right I bet you're Quebecois
For those who are like What does that mean?
That's like sort of like The Canadian insult The people who
disagree Like And so Here's a little Canadian history.
But like, even if Canadians disagree with each other, they
can all agree that like the Quebec Wall is important.
The Quebec people in Quebec, they can all agree that they do
not like the people in Quebec.
And if you're from Quebec, bro, you know it's true.
You know it's true.
He didn't, bro, okay, here's a little story.
I have a friend from Quebec, and then he told me, like, yo,
yeah, I was like, oh, shit, where are you from, Canada?
I was like, Quebec, and I was like, oh, Quebec, and he's
like, I know.
And he was like, bro, I hate it.
It's because, like, okay, the reason why Quebec is, like,
has this reputation is that Quebec, Quebec has always tried
to like like piece off from Canada because like Quebec has
like their own like fucking like they're like it's oh so
it's like if like if like a random state in America has
their own like party has their own political party and like
they make like lots of demands and stuff so like Quebec has
their own party called a Qubcois I think I remember how it
was like the Quebecois, right, it's like they have their own
political party and like at one point in Canadian history
they try to vote to be like their own fucking basically they
try to vote to be their own country and they try to vote to
be not Canada and try to be like their own like like their
own like fucking independent country in the middle of Canada
Not once, but twice.
So people are like, but you can't be quiet.
So that's why like every Canadian can agree that like you
can't be like the goddamn chemicoat.
It's like a, it's like a little, it's a little like running
joke in Canada.
uh this way here we go actually texas but in canada
okay but yeah it's a little it's a little quebec fun fact a
little a little canadian fun fact um and so it's a little
it's and like it's like i'll just say like you know when a
canadian is from Quebec.
It's actually funny because, like, if it tells you anything,
XQC is from Quebec.
And, like, a lot... Like, the thing is, a lot of people from
Quebec are very similar to, like, how XQC is like.
Like...
Like, I've met so many people from Quebec that has a very
similar personality to, like, XQC.
And that was, like, before he like blew up like before he
became like a super a super big streamer and like there were
like you know before like people started emulating him and
stuff but like a lot of people in quebec act very similar
all right yeah of course he's canadian yeah he's from quebec
he's quebec
A little fun fact there Where the fuck do I go?
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That explains a lot All right, bro, I watched this I watched
the stream Speaking as a as a little French Canadian.
Yeah, we're a little funny Emily's thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
Look, I was right Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dark Blade.
How dare you call me a Kamequa?
I'm writing my Castle Doki Twitlogger right now.
The explanation works right to show my seriousness.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I said it.
Now, where do I go?
Where do I fucking go?
I'm so lost.
Why am I always lost?
Turn left.
My greatest enemy.
This is this way?
It must be this way.
Am I going back here?
Okay, it must be this way.
Right?
Oh my god!
Tell me where to go!
God!
me God oh my God would tell me like how to kill but they
won't tell me where to go this fucking sucks all right okay
I'm gonna fucking use this oh my god I get fucking launched.
All right.
This.
It's like here.
How the fuck do I get there?
All right.
This way.
That passed it?
How do I pass it?
I don't know where it is.
I ran past it.
Here's some yellow part of your paint.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
you.
How the fuck do I pass it?
I don't even know where it is.
It's like here.
It's a cave?
Oh, it's a cave.
Okay, now I need to look for the holes in the rocks.
Alright.
There has to be a hole in the rock somewhere.
Where the fuck is the hole in the rock?
Alright.
I gotta run in a circle again.
Wait, are there any fruit in this tree?
There is.
Okay.
Yes, time.
That's a fruit, right?
Yeah, that has to be a fruit.
Okay.
I almost forgot how to use my fucking bow.
This is one tiny fruit.
Where the fuck did it go?
Where the fuck did the fruit go?
Hello?
Did the fucking ground absorb the fruit?
Like, excuse me?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it was a pineapple.
Yum.
Okay, it was like camouflaged.
Alright, let's see.
Boop.
Wait, do pineapples?
Pineapples don't grow on trees.
What a...
It's not a pineapple?
What the fuck kind of fruit is this?
What kind of genetic mutations of a fruit is this?
It's not a pineapple.
Pineapples...
Oh my god, when I saw what a pineapple tree looks like, what
a pineapple plant looks like, they do?
No, they don't.
They grow on the fucking ground.
You guys have never seen a fucking pineapple plant They're
like it's like some it's like okay, it's like a giant.
It's like a fucking grass and then like a fucking giant
pineapple in the middle It's so fucking weird.
I never like realized how fucking weird Pineapple trees are
like not pineapple trees, but like a pineapple plant They're
like bushes.
Yeah, like they it's like a pineapple bush You think that
pineapples come from a tree, but But it's like a bush.
Look up like, look up like a pineapple bush or something.
And then you'll see what I mean.
It's so fucking weird.
It's literally like a bush.
It's not even like a real tree.
Oh yeah, selective breeding.
Oh yeah, no, we fucking did a lot of that type of shit.
I was, I've been like getting like YouTube shorts of
people's selective breeding like silk moss or whatever.
code and then like apparently like we like uh we selected
breed like uh silk mobs so much that their wings don't even
work like their wings their wings don't even work and that
they're only when they when they like uh come out their
cocoons all they do is want to fuck and then they their
mouths don't even work their mouths are like like their
brain is just they want to bang so they don't eat for five
day like three to five days they don't eat for three to five
days and all they do is just bang and then they die like
they come out of their cocoons they come out of their cell
cocoons bang for three to five day like bang for like three
to five days and die that's like their life cycle that's
it's off it's so fucked up they have a mouth but They don't
know how to use the mouth.
And apparently their guts are so fucked.
Their guts don't even work.
It's so messed up.
It's on the other...
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get on the other side of the cave?
And then, like, the lady, the lady was like, oh yeah, like,
we selectively bred the moths so much that, like, these
moths, the male moths don't even know how to...
to detach i was like what do you mean they don't know how to
like i was like i was like they're like the youtube short
lady was like yes we selectively bred these mobs so much
that like the males just don't know how to detach so you
have to intervene and like detach them yourselves i was like
why it's like yes like I have to like detach them myself or
the females won't be able to lay their eggs because all the
males what I do is bang and I'm like bro oh my god bro
they're poor I was like what the fuck bro that's so fucked
up oh my god an actual shrine I haven't found a shrine in
forever yeah Yeah, oh yeah, the big the bushes make only one
pineapple It's actually crazy pineapple bushes only they
only make one pineapple there's a giant fucking pineapple in
the middle of a bush nice prey They made them to whoa what
the fuck he's right here.
That's looking nice.
He's literally right here.
Whoop Thank you for like just sitting there He literally was
like hey, I haven't seen a pineapple in 20 years new friend
and I'm like yes new friend all right let's see it's maybe
here oh my god nice thank god for that lizard for letting me
eat him new friend time to eat him the survival instinct of
a silkworm this has to be the cave there's no other cave It
has to be the cave.
Alright, I'm just gonna fucking walk now.
Alright, Arlo, I'm just gonna walk.
Here we go.
Time to kill you.
I mean, time to rehabilitate this person.
Don't worry, sir.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, man.
Sorry, my solar powered GPS doesn't work here.
Alright, we gotta run up.
Alright.
Time to fucking go.
Hey, Doki, how do I know if acupuncture is right for me?
I'm tall and the back of my arms hurt.
Is that a requirement?
Skellum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, as a professional licensed acupuncture
specialist.
Wait, give me a sec.
I need to, let me, give me a sec.
My solar power, GPS needs to tell me where to go.
Give me a sec.
All right.
Thank you.
What a good question.
Alright, so like if you if you touch under your arm And you
feel all the the stress juices coming out right now Like you
feel the stress juices underneath your skin suit That means
you're like super stressed out So like all that like liquid
in your arm right there It's like those are like the stress
toxins building up So
Is the stress toxins building up your arm so like obviously
if you want to try a home remedy i would highly suggest so
like if you want to try a home remedy yet as a specialist by
the way don't try this at home but what i would do is that i
would get like a really like you know like a very sharp
needle just like the sword you know and just like just just
like the sword you know like and just start Digging the
stress toxins out.
But obviously don't do that.
Do not do that.
I am a professional.
Contact your local acupuncture artist.
Contact your local acupuncture artist to help you get that
toxin out.
I am a specialist so I can do it.
Look at all the colossus that gave me glowing reviews.
Where the fuck do I go?
here is it inside here yes do not perform acupuncture on
yourself contact your local specialist oh my god my solar
powered story does not work right now i what oh my oh it's
like over there okay i see it i see it now i see the tempo i
see a tempo all right disclaimer by the way and you guys was
just a joke um i am a professional so i am legally allowed
to do stuff like this bro a gps sword that's solar powered
has to be the worst fucking sword has to be the worst
fucking gps device because it's like what if it's nighttime
what if it's nighttime and not to kill a colossus how would
that work i have a like where's your license where's your
fucking Right here
Any lawyers in chat I must have a lawyer dragoon right now
Any dragoon lawyers in chat Here to verify my very legal
license Where's a notary?
I must have a notary here I need a notary right now Pop-up
court Thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you As an
actual license massage Therapist, I'm smiling, but I'm
shaking my head.
Papa, Corey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because you're shaking your head at the chatters, right?
Because you're like, I can't believe these people in chat
does not know, like, basic fucking massage stuff.
Bro, I know, Corey.
I fucking know.
I can't believe they doubt our fucking skills.
Just because you don't see massage therapy.
Just because you doubt.
my skills doesn't mean i'm wrong i don't think this is it i
don't know oh no there's a real one yes me i'm the real one
what the fuck do you mean oh no there's a real one you've
been watching a real massage therapist this entire time
all right here we go
all right we must go this way i want to What if Arlo can get
here?
Arlo, can you get up here?
Hello?
Can you get up here?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The significance of your certificates seems forged.
What are you?
A real lawyer?
Come back when you have a law degree.
Thank you for the super chat.
Where's your fucking law degree?
Are you a notary?
fucking right post your fucking degree right now but like
don't dox yourself post tap post your real degree on Twitter
right now in my bird seeders tag but also do not dox
yourself make sure the censored like the just so you know
but Also, I only take Ivy Leagues.
I...
I only take Ivy Leagues.
Degrees.
Alright, how the fuck do I get downstairs?
Alright.
Oh yeah.
And it has...
And it has to be like...
How the fuck do I get downstairs?
Oh, this way.
be a Canadian oh my god a Canadian university that is
equivalent to because American massage laws are not the same
as Canadian massage parlor laws checkmate
alright what are these requirements these are all the
requirements to like alright wait is He mean?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, he mean.
He's mean.
He a mean guy.
He's not happy.
Sir, I'm ready for your appointment, sir.
Sir, don't worry.
I'm ready for our, sir.
Sir, I'm ready for our appointment.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
We're still okay.
Where do I fuck do I shoot?
His legs?
Sir, here's the acupuncture right now.
Oh, he didn't like that.
Oh, did I do it?
Okay.
Did I get fall damage from that?
No, I don't.
Okay, I'm coming over, sir!
Don't worry, everybody likes a
bro!
Okay, time to slap the dick.
Don't worry!
I am also a licensed veterinarian!
lizards out there we need to make sure we fix the lizard
population
guys i am only trying to fix the lizard over population as
well i just got my veterinarian degree too chat so i'm here
to fix the i'm here to fix the it's like when there's too
many cats and you got neutered the cats that's what i'm
doing it's a tough job but like there's There's too many
cats.
Too many lizards in the world.
You saw the lizards?
You all saw how many lizards there were out there.
I'm a licensed veterinarian.
I'm here to solve the overpopulation.
He's acupuncture in that.
And neutering services?
Um, it's neutering services.
you wouldn't understand what the fuck there you go no is he
not like it when I shoot his toes where the fuck is his
other toe there it is there you all right sir we have a
problem your late night your late night fucking rumps are an
issue sir where the fuck is the wait that's stab everything
where oh it's because I didn't have my sword out sir I was
like where the fuck is your dick I was like bro I didn't
know I was that good of at my job bro I just thought I was
really good at my job I thought I was really good at like
neutering you're nearing lizards I don't know I don't know I
just thought I just got it in the first try all right he's
got a climb got a climb get over here bro you can't just yes
i can it's part of new only licensed veterinarians can fact
check me are you a license don't talk to me unless you don't
fact check me unless you're a licensed
veterinarian that's right i bet you're not even a licensed
veterinarian all right oh wait okay we gotta stab the heart
now so he can stop falling in love with all these lizards
it's good for you it's good for you you need you are
contributing to the problem oh my where am i bro get out
guys we gotta like make sure he never fuzzens up again too
Oh my god.
I don't think he liked that.
Look.
Look at all these iguanas in like LA.
They are an invasive species because of you.
He did not look like...
That's so crazy.
I wonder why he didn't like that.
I neutered him.
That's so fucking crazy.
You guys do know like iguanas are like an invasive species.
It was like some fucking state where like iguanas became
invasive species and like there's like an order now There's
like a fucking state order where like if you see an iguana
you gotta kill it because because there's too many iguanas
That are like destroying the fucking city.
Is it Florida?
Yeah There's like a state order now where like if you see a
fucking iguana in Florida You gotta fucking kill it because
there's too many iguanas Juana's is that's actually fucking
wild I didn't and it's all because of him Yeah, they're like
actually kill on site All right, sir, this is why you
contributed to the problem I quite a population all because
of this one guy he got that's why we had to fucking neuter
him Some people just eat it oh my god it's back to the dick
what bro the last oh my god get me out get me out the last
he's like no i will never stop the final shot guys i didn't
finish my job there's still babies in there i didn't finish
my job all right this is why there's an iguana a problem in
florida this is exactly why where the fuck is he how do i
get out of here oh shiny heal oh i didn't even realize give
me a sec sir i'm gonna heal give me a sec they hatched it
and it felt more uncomfortable but i can't look away he grew
it back he had two like in a kid now or some shit I forgot
to snip one more from the neuter service.
Don't worry.
Kandoki, the massage therapist, and your local neuter
services for lizards only.
I can only work on lizards, though.
Nothing else.
Look at that.
Guys, I'm so talented.
Of course you would contact your local massage therapist for
lizard neutered.
All right.
Let's poke.
Oh, one more hit.
One more hit.
Don't worry.
You don't need kids.
You can't afford all the fucking child services.
Not child service.
Sorry, the what is it?
You can't afford the the payments
It's the opposite of a happy ending child support.
Yeah, child support All right Nice It's okay.
He couldn't afford the child support anyway Guys, he
literally caused a Florida iguana epidemic.
We gotta get rid of him.
Just like how barbers are used to perform surgery.
Oh, she's awake!
I did it!
Look at that, it's so fucking easy.
Look, I have to have multiple jobs to afford taking care oh
it was just a dream god damn bro i'm just after neutering
that giant lizard i'm getting homesick for my boo he heard
she heard the iguana problem was over
please wake oh my gosh she's so dead look at her fucking
skin yeah that's dead bro why is it she not like rotting
away that she looked so good.
That's like dead dead skin.
And she's not trying to be a fucking goth girl.
Yep.
Are you dead?
Yep, dead.
But she's... I feel like...
Oh, a tree is near you, girl.
It sleeps in a dry lake.
Another fucking lake?
But now it's a dead lake?
Are you fucking good?
How many lakes are there?
Oh my god.
Not to find a dead lake.
An empty lake.
More lakes.
Alright.
Time to pray.
Save the pray, chat.
Save the pray.
Boop.
Oh.
Save the pray.
At least three more.
There's three fucking lakes.
bro three different lakes this is why i would never survive
in like the old the olden times all right where do i go
where is the the fucking dead lake it is behind me okay this
is it it's behind me come on if i make you go forward maybe
you'll turn by yourself okay no i have to physically turn
Arlo.
Arlo, go!
Isn't a dry lake just lag?
No, because fucking dry lakes has a hole.
This way.
Okay.
Go, Arlo!
Go!
Take me to the dry lake!
We'll assume that dry lakes, there's a hole to make the dry
lake.
Okay, this is the normal lake.
Where the fuck is dry lake?
Let's go to the side?
Is it the other side?
Oh, it is.
Okay, we gotta... How do I get to the... Oh, okay, this way.
All right, Arlo, time to get to the other side.
I guess, like, I follow this pathway.
I'll go.
Please.
Arlo, please.
Please, you're better than this.
You used to be a main character.
What the fuck happened?
Okay, do I have to turn?
No.
Okay.
thank god arlo can can walk for me now a nice relaxing
squirrel you know i think i'm doing really well my business
a license a license massage all right massage parlor owner
and a and a veterinarian get a get a man that can do both
guys ladies ladies i am basically I am basically the dream
husband material.
I can perform neuters and also give you a massage.
I can fix the iguana.
The iguana pandemic.
And also...
That's so high.
Holy shit, Ola.
What the fuck was that?
Bro, this is like the first time he did something actually
badass.
It's because they're so fucking relaxed that they never get
stressed again.
Like, you won't understand.
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
They were so fucking stressed out that they like, um, how
the fuck do I get to the other side, though?
They were so stressed out that I relaxed them so much with
my massage and acupuncture that, like, they just never had
to come back.
I basically relieved them of their stress.
Punch stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doki, the dream daddy.
I mean, husband.
Okay, this way.
Okay, I need to go.
Alright.
We need to go this way, Arlo.
This has to be it.
There's like tornadoes.
There's like little mini tornadoes stuff.
Oh, shit.
This is gonna be hard.
Oh, no.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this Colossi already.
Bro, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Am I in like the geysers?
Bro, what the fuck is this?
Where even is the?
What the fuck is the Colossi?
Did I miss it?
Where is he?
Yeah, the Yellowstone.
Did I miss it?
Where the fuck is he?
He's like here.
He's in the cave?
Why are you all in the cave?
Get out!
Get a job!
Get out of that cave and get a job!
It's time!
It's time to move out!
See the sun!
I am here.
hired by your mom to tell you to get out of that cave.
The cave is safe.
But the cave feels so safe, Doki.
Is it that?
That looks like a cave turtle.
Is that rock?
Am I going the right way?
Oh, no.
Like, it says, like, the colossi is, like, right here.
Am I going the right way?
Go back?
Okay.
no go back to the geyser oh the geyser okay i'll go back to
the geyser i passed it where the fuck did i pass it i can't
even tell where it is it says here all right get out your
mom hired i'm your life coach too i got a new job
I am now also become a life coach.
Your mom hired me to turn your life around.
Where the fuck is that guy?
Where the fuck is this John ass turtle?
Is it here?
Is this a cave?
This is a cave.
You don't need a license to be a life coach.
You just gotta win at life.
As someone who goes to therapy, daily I am gonna get your
life around as someone that goes to therapy I can help you
change your life do not worry do not worry where the fuck is
the geyser I assume I have to make lead him to the geyser
and then he goes like you or something.
It's fine.
I got it.
I got this, Arlo.
Don't worry!
I know what I'm doing!
Get over here!
Woo!
Come on, get over here.
Oh, I do need Arlo.
Why the fuck do I need Arlo?
I'll just go over the geyser.
Right?
whoa whoa whoa i don't like that whoa hello get over here
apparently i do need you poke poke okay why do i need arlo
i'll find out why over come on you like the little geyser is
it like a little body rub like i don't oh
What the fuck do I do?
Is he is he getting like a little shower?
Is he liking that?
Like I'm so confused.
Does he like the little fucking belly shower?
I'm like trying to figure out how to Oh, I gotta get closer
all right here you go oh i see oh arlo don't be a charlo
it's just a little fire all right here you go don't worry
i'm gonna turn your life around oh i gotta climb that i
gotta climb the tail i gotta climb the tail right okay i got
you no No, get back down.
You got you.
Where else would I climb?
Nice.
No, what?
What do I climb?
Shit.
I cannot climb the tail?
Okay, I figured it's not the tail.
It's not the tail.
Oh, I have to climb the fucking legs.
Where the fuck do I climb on the list?
Oh, I can't shoot that.
I can't shoot that.
Arlo!
I'm your favorite owner!
Alright.
Oh, God.
All right, I didn't lead him to the geyser before.
Does he have to go to the geyser again?
Come to the geyser.
Look at this funny geyser.
That's what I assume I have to do.
Oh, it has to be perfectly under his shell.
Oh, okay.
Oh, is that a shell?
That is!
Oh my god, that is!
How is that non-climbing?
I don't!
Please!
Get out!
How do I flip him over?
Help!
Oh my god, this one fucking sucks.
I hate this one so much.
Oh my god.
I'm choking.
I'm choking already.
Wait, okay.
Just stand there again.
Just make that same mistake, sir.
Bro, fucking stop Arlo!
Arlo!
Oh my god, just stand underneath the geyser again.
perfectly do it again for me is he oh yes he is he is he is
okay okay i'm gonna jump i'm gonna jump
oh god oh god oh god oh god with what my fucking bow what do
i hit him with
oh god oh god oh i see it I see it!
I see it!
It's green!
Poke.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Do it again!
Do it again, please!
Please do it!
Oh my god, don't worry, I have it Nice, okay, I can do it
again Oh, thank god, I can Please, please just get up
Okay, okay, one more Alright, I won't choke this time, I
swear Oh my god, I fucking did it Oh my god, I fucking I
fucking I fucking
Oh my god.
Go.
Go, Doki.
I am your person alive, coach.
Do not worry.
I am here to coach you!
Where the fuck is it?
Where do I coach him?
Where do I?
I do!
My sword is literally up!
No!
Over!
This is the fucker flip!
Where's the guys here?
Oh my god, where the fuck's the guys?
I didn't know where he comes so lost in peace.
Okay, I understand now.
I understand.
I understand now, guys.
I figured it out, guys.
Don't be disappointed in me.
I figured it out.
It took me.
Look, every person I coach in life is different, okay?
So, like, because of that, I have to, like, figure out what
they want, what they want in front of their lives.
It's okay, I figured it out.
I just need them to get closer.
Get closer!
Okay, Arlo, please don't get close to me.
I'm talking about this guy.
Get him on, get over here.
Walk over here!
Walk!
Bro, you can't just be lazy!
Your mom tells you to go outside!
Okay.
Okay, that is on you, Arlo.
That is 100% on you, Arlo.
That is not on me.
That is not on me, man.
What the fuck?
How is he able to do that?
Oh, wait.
He gets to...
Oh, he's talking falls again.
Oh, I just need to take him to the geyser all the time.
I get it now.
I get it.
Go, go, go, go.
Go.
Go, Doki, go.
Okay.
How do I?
Go.
Go, go, come on, come on!
Climbing.
Climbing, dokey.
Keep climbing!
I'm climbing!
I'm doing it!
Oh my god.
Please keep climbing.
Keep climbing.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Okay, I'm just going to hold on.
Yeah!
What?
Holy shit.
What the fuck was that?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Holy shit.
What do I do?
I'm stuck.
Oh god.
Oh my god, I made it, I made it, oh my god, I made it, I
fucking made it, oh!
Grip, grip, where the fuck is this fucking, where the fuck
is the acupuncture hole?
Oh, there he is, look, I don't want to do this, but your mom
was very specific in her instructions.
look you have to get out of that cave bro your mom said
you've been living in that cave for 20 years after college
you haven't seen the day yet it's like big brother but it's
like a one-man show you have to touch grass your mom is so
worried But don't worry, your personal life coach is here.
And I'm here to get rid of all your worries here.
This is like a patented dokey bird special.
Attack you, man.
This is what life coaches are for.
Do not worry.
Look, you have to go outside.
Go to that gym.
And like, touch some grass, man.
worried.
I say, what do I do?
Let's not think about that.
When did the last time I went outside?
Let's see.
Look, I am your life coach.
My life coach handles me and not you.
That's different.
We did it.
Doki Bird, life coach, vet, massage therapist, and
lobotomous.
Thank you, Thank you.
Yeah, thank you again, first name.
Yay, I did it.
I finally...
Look at him!
He's ready to go outside!
I took him to grass.
That is a job well done for the Doki Bird professional life
coach.
I coached him so hard that he went outside and touched some
grass.
Good for him.
He's so full of life And so alive Oh my god And his mom
carried me back to the temple
Yay Another job well done How many more colossi Do I have
left?
Or colossus do I have left?
Five right?
Because I did
Now you're gonna meet those colossi Arlo riding skills Okay
That was nine, I believe.
An isolated sand dune.
Its tracks are well hidden.
I was six left.
I did nine?
Okay.
I thought I did ten.
What did I do?
I only did four today, right?
Alright.
It's time to test up my riding skills.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm a professional.
You guys have already seen how good i am at at driving a
horse it's time it's time to go to the sand snakes all right
pray pray the save oh sorry that's not praying all right
back to being a massage therapist it was nice experimenting
with different jobs but i feel like it's time to go back to
what i'm really passionate about Distressing acupuncture.
Okay, let's see where it is.
It's like this way.
Okay.
Alright, Arlo.
It's time.
It's time to drive my horse over.
Alright, here we go.
Is it this way?
It's this way.
Okay.
Think?
It has to be.
Is it across the ocean again?
my true passion being a very licensed massage parlor owner
that is my only passion apparently which I 100% agree with
why the fuck do I get to the other side I think I need to oh
I need to cross the bridge sir okay I need to cross the
bridge to the other side I need to cross it here right can I
cross it that way did I go to wrong way?
Do I cross it here?
This way?
I guess?
Let's see.
I don't cross this area.
Here?
Here, and then I go all the way over there.
Okay, I guess I go here, and then I go left, I think.
all right we're gonna go to the other side now don't worry
this is the furthest appointment I'll have to go but don't
worry Colossus I am a licensed professional and I'll be here
to cure all your stress stupid snake why are you in the sand
all right I think it's this way right Where does my sword
GPS tell me?
I need to call my client and tell them that I might be a
little late.
My sword GPS is a little faulty.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god.
See, look at that.
See?
Look at the way I drive my horse.
Fucking professional horse driver.
Woo!
Oh,
hello, birdie.
Where the fuck is the sand?
Where is the...
Where is the sand?
This is not the sand.
Is it going the right way?
I am.
This is the only way to go.
Right?
Yeah, because that's the ocean.
So the sand has to be nearby.
Because when there's an ocean, there's sand.
It's on a cave?
I had to fucking go downstairs?
No way.
There's no way.
Is it Doki a horse girl?
I'm actually not a horse girl.
I never got to be a horse girl.
So now, because I never got to be a horse girl, I can live
through it now.
Because I never got a chance to.
I get to see what it was like to be a horse girl.
All right.
Let's see.
I don't think it's here.
Is it not?
Where the fuck is the desert?
Why does it keep pointing down?
Oh, it's because I keep walking down.
I was like, what is my sword?
Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
Okay, it's this way.
All right.
Guys, I figured it out.
If you look down the sword, the sword GPS.
That game takes me downstairs.
So I just need to not look down.
Oh, hey.
Maybe I can grab some HP.
If I grab HP from here...
Oh, my God.
I thought I was going to fucking die.
I thought Arlo was going to send me down to the cliffs.
Okay, did I chew the fruit from here before?
No, oh, I didn't.
Alright.
Okay, whoops.
That was the camera.
Alright.
Boop.
That has to be one of the fruits.
eat nice yeah I don't have a lot of stamina I haven't been
finding shrines there's another one get away Arlo pew
alright where the fuck did the fruits drop to hello oh here
yay and then fruit fruit nice alright Alright, time to
figure out where the desert is.
Okay, time to go to Snake Boy.
The fuck?
Oh, nope.
GPS sword.
Where do you... Oh, sorry.
Not in the sun.
GPS sword.
Tell me where to go!
Alright, GPS sword has spoken.
Alright, Arlo.
Get over here.
Look.
I'm a good owner.
All right, Arlo.
Apparently I need you to help me with the snake.
It's always a cave.
Why are they always all in caves?
What happened to them?
Why is it always a cave?
This has to be sad, right?
This is it?
No, that's not sad.
That's normal grass.
No one tells...
Oh, oh, shrine!
Shrine!
Wait, have I been to the shrine before?
No, I haven't.
This is new.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Alright, Arlo.
Oh, there it is!
There's a cave!
There's a sand cave!
I knew my GPS sword will take me to the right place.
Okay, time to pray.
Wait, this is not... Wait, what?
Okay, I was like, wait a minute.
Time to pray.
Alright, where the fuck is the gecko?
Now that I've fixed the iguana problem, this should be...
Oh, there he is.
Arlo, please.
Okay.
Is he dead dead?
No.
Now he is.
Alright.
You always gotta double tap.
What the fuck?
You're a lie?
Oh, it's okay.
He can regrow the tail!
I let him live on purpose because I found out you can regrow
the tail.
You come back to the shrine and then the tail will grow
back.
real just from from the dokeybird exclusive you guys might
not know that it's like a hidden easter egg the tail will
regrow so you have to you have to like the thing is you have
to like shoot it at the tail at the right part of the tail
so like um because mostly people when they shoot it they
kill the lizard but like if you're as skilled as me you can
shoot at the tail that only the tail comes off and not the
lizard the lizard doesn't die so like i know like a lot of
people might not as me but like but here's a little pro tip
it's a one frame trick that I mastered also you have to
shoot at the right angle so like you come back to the shrine
and then the lizard will have is how you can farm unlimited
stamina all right how the fuck do I kill the snake let's
ride around and just jump on the back oh Oh, God.
He seems very angry.
Do not worry.
Oh, my God.
It's the anger stress.
You know, when you're so stressed out, you're just angry.
That's just him.
Don't worry.
That's why I got hired in the first place.
My word of mouth.
My word of mouth is working.
I don't need to waste money advertising and getting YouTube
ads.
My happy clients are advertising about my great...
My great, um, my great work ethics.
How do I fucking kill him?
Don't step on the snake, but what if I want to step on the
snake?
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I'm getting sucked in!
Come on, I get it, I get it.
Okay, I get it now.
I was getting sucked in.
I was losing HP.
I just realized I was losing HP.
I was like, whoa, I definitely did not fucking have that low
HP when I started.
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell, guys.
Is he?
Whoa!
Bro, he's a crocodile!
it's a crocodile snake holy shit oh my god do I have to
shoot the eye are you fucking how do I oh my god I figured
it out I have to shoot the eye I figured it out oh my god
can you see he's gonna run into a wall oh my god okay I
thought Arlo can like figure this out himself oh I like
looked back and I saw eyes i was like i have to shoot the
eye oh my god don't worry as we all know the okay this you
guys might not actually you guys actually might not know
this because you're not into our acupuncture but like the
most risky all right the most expensive acupuncture job is
are you serious did he fucking hit the what rock
Come on.
The most expensive acupuncture job out there is the eye of
acupuncture.
Like you gotta be super...
You gotta be like super fucking pr- You gotta be like super
precise with this.
Do not worry, I am a professional.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Where do I?
There we go.
Eye acupuncture.
Do not worry.
Okay, oh, I found it instantly.
Yes, for when you shoot the eye, you reveal all the stress
points.
Yeah, that guy has some fucking...
That's when you know.
Like that eye, you know he needed eye acupuncture right
there.
I basically relieved all the eye stress from him.
Oh shit, he fucking buried me.
Oh my god, okay.
Arlo, Arlo, Arlo.
We gotta get the other eye, Arlo.
Oh my god, I need a fucking eye.
Arlo, don't worry.
Don't worry, Arlo.
I am a professional.
Okay, he has to go this way, right?
Right?
Yeah, he has to follow me from behind.
What the fuck?
Now he can jump.
That's when you know he liked it.
It's okay, it's because he's been looking at the PC.
When you look at the PC for too long for a lot for when you
look at the PC for too long for like majority of your life,
you gotta get acupuncture.
But like you have to get it with a real professional like
me.
So if you have, if you see this license from any specialist,
um, that's what, that, like, my particular license states
that, like, I am allowed to perform IQ puncher.
Where the fuck is he so slow?
Show up.
Only one, one, oh, oh no, what are you doing?
oh my god that was so scary what the fuck okay
oh my god that was so fucking scary man what the fuck arlo
arlo arlo i don't like that i don't like that arlo where the
fuck is the eye open your eye bro only one out of five
specialists.
Oh, wait.
He's tired?
Why is he tired?
Only one out of five specialists can perform this.
Oh, I get tired from fucking drawing my bow.
I didn't even realize that.
I'm so fucking weak.
Oh, shit.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
No, no!
Oh, they hit him!
They hit him!
I did right!
Oh, I did!
Okay, thank God.
I couldn't tell.
Oh my god, I couldn't tell.
Get off, get off the horse.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, Go, go, go, go.
Where the fuck is your?
Where the fuck is your stress?
Where are you stress, my boy?
No, okay, I found the stress point.
Bam, all right, don't worry
Five clients recommend me the fifth one forgot to leave a
review
There we go we did it look the people just forgot to leave
the review okay we did it we cured stress can't call me for
iacupuncture one out of five specialists and i'm the
cheapest one not because i'm bad at it it's because like i
know being a specialist is like really like you know i know
it's like we're really in demand and because like i care
about the people you the people so i make sure i'm super
affordable for those who need eye acupuncture that's why
it's like i'm like the cheapest out of all four or five of
them i do it for the people
yeah i gotta make it like financially available it's like
it's like what is it insulin i'm it's like insulin i'm like
that guy that tried to make insulin cheaper that's me I
wouldn't like let big pharma take advantage of you
Yay I did it What does God want me to do now?
Who's the next one?
Galerania set loose It keeps the...
Oh wait, fire?
This is the fire guardian The fire colossus
is this another lake
oh my god you know what I think this is the perfect time to
call it we'll do we'll do the last the last six on another
stream I don't want I don't want to find another lake let's
pray right now let's pray pray time yay I think we made it
Oh, good progress.
Chat.
We made so much progress today.
Guys.
We made so much progress.
Alright, let me...
Let me swap screens.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I did it.
There we go.
Did I pray?
I'm gonna pray again just in case.
That was really fun though.
This game has been, like, super enjoyable so far.
I'm really glad I actually got a chance.
I actually get the chance to keep playing Shadow Colossus.
Because it's been, like, super fun so far.
And definitely, like, I really enjoyed playing it for the
very first time.
But I'm going to do something about Super Chat Reading.
We haven't done those in so long.
Because I've always been so busy.
And I still am very busy.
But I figured today's the day.
Today's the day we do a super chat reading.
Let me find the text that pops up and be like, doing super
chat reading right now.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh my god.
It's been so long that I can't even find like the little
text that tells people I'm doing super chat reading.
Oh, there it is.
I just didn't color code it.
All right, colors.
All right, donation reading time.
Yeah!
I had it really fun.
It's been like, we're going to finish this.
We're going to finish Shadow Colossus.
next week guys don't worry next week we're gonna 100 finish
it i just figured like i didn't want to do like a super long
stream um like i don't want to force myself to do all all
all the colossus uh today so uh purposely wanted to leave it
though all the rest for last stream because i don't know how
long it's gonna take me i i don't know how long the last the
last six colossis are gonna take me so i was like you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna leave it to the last stream just in
case just just in case i get like fucked up um uh let's see
let me pull it's been a while i almost forgot how to do a
super chat reading yeah pull it up real fast uh earn supas
poop all right where was i let's see uh metty thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you horse girl streams woo
ginger thank you for the super chat thank you thank you not
so dead poor please donky i don't want to see the stamina
bar it distracts me thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you look i am so nice i'm so nice i actually showed
you guys the stamina bar i usually never do that you guys
have to a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity um let's see uh uh
uh cas thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
the art contest for your gamer substar the fifth right did
you have any specific details for the artist entering okay
so there's been a delay uh since there's no there's no been
no details regarding the uh regarding the art contest
because we're working on the graphic the art contest um
there was like some delay because we were like finalizing
the rules and everything uh but uh so don't worry because i
didn't post anything it just means like the official contest
isn't out yet um but uh the moment i get the graphics for
the to to post it that's when like you know boom we start so
um uh so that's just like um that's just basically it the
reason why they're like you know i know we said fifth but
there's been delays and stuff there's just a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes every day i've been like super
duper busy because there's been so many things that delay
like not delayed but like um there's just been a lot of
things that's just being worked on like it takes longer to
process and stuff like that and um um oh good news i started
work on an original song
to work on an original song today um so that's like some
some good news to look for i don't know when when when it's
gonna be but uh i'm starting work on an original song with a
uh with one of my favorite composers so i'm super looking
forward to it um um but yeah that's something to look
forward to i don't know look a lot of these take a lot of
time though oh my god wait i really want like i really want
to spoil you guys on something really fucking dumb i'm
planning but i can't it's so stupid yesterday i received
something and like yesterday i received something and it was
so fucking guy like i i commissioned this and it's so
fucking dumb i really wish i could show it to you guys but i
can't i have to like i'm trying not to but one day you'll
know one day whenever i finish setting everything up for the
really dumb thing i commissioned and like i could finally
show you guys you'll know why i was like it's so dumb
you'll know why when i said it was so dumb but like it was
so worth it one day it'll be like a very special stream uh
chris thank you for the super chat thank you Thank you.
I'm excited for the end of the saga.
If you haven't said it yet, where do we commission you for
tomorrow's icon drawing stream?
Thank you, let's do a chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, regarding the icon stuff, we actually made a Google
form.
One of the mods and I, well, one of the mods.
Shout out to the silent mod for making a Google form where
you can submit like, like you, like a receipt.
Obviously, like, we'll have like a template and everything
for you guys to look at the Google form where you'll be
submitting.
like your receipt and stuff of like your purchase of that
super chat for the icon um but like if you have never
commissioned me it'll just be on the member stream um but
for the previous commissions in the past like when you've
commissioned me on the previous streams you just have to
submit that and then like proof that you know oh you've like
uh you've commissioned me in the past and like here is like
what you're and your icon your youtube icon and everything
so that's all going to be The members post will have all the
details.
I'll be making it tonight.
After the stream, after I, like, you know, get dinner and
everything, I'll be making the...
I'll be...
Yeah, we know the dates.
We know what the dates of the stream is.
We'll have all the details for everybody on the...
If you're a member, we'll have all the details in the
community post.
So you guys don't have to be like, I don't know how to do
this.
So do not worry.
We'll give you guys the details of how to find the receipt
and everything.
should be in your youtube it should be in the email
associated to your youtube or like it could be in like your
super chat so don't worry you'll see it in the community
post when we when we like organize everything uh when i post
a community post um many thank you the super chat thank you
get thank you also gamer subs creator code thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh my god i didn't know being
a gamer sub partner we get like free like okay i know we get
like free stuff sometimes but like i received an email today
that was like you have made an order to like gamer subs and
i was like huh i was like what obviously i can't read what
the order is because i think they're like flavors and like
cups that haven't been released yet because i was like
looking at it i was like what the fuck i was like i didn't
make an order
I was like, I didn't make an order.
What is this?
And I looked at it.
I was like, wait, what are these flavors?
I think like when you're a gamer sub-partner, they give you
like, like new, the flavor, like the newest flavors that
come out or something or the newest like waifu cup.
So like you like test it out and stuff.
Obviously I'm not going to say what the flavor was because
like I'm pretty sure it's not even out in public.
Like I'm pretty sure.
it's not because I like looked at I was like what flavor is
this and I like Googled it and like it didn't exist and I
was like oh oh shit okay it's like yeah like I'm beta
testing it or something because I was like I didn't order
anything what the fuck is this
um so yeah I was just like wait a minute oh my god that's
gonna exist I'm pretty sure like when you're a gamer sub
partner just send you like like free like free samples of
like the flavors themselves so you to test it out and stuff
um well i haven't well i haven't received it i just
literally got it i literally like got the email today um
links thank you for the super chat thank you thank you glad
i made it in time saw the total solar eclipse today it was a
surreal experience i was sleeping yay also like isn't there
like another one in october or august like i saw like people
were like oh my god the solar eclipse and i was like solar
eclipse and i like looked it up there's another one coming
in like august and and october there's one every yeah
there's one every year so i was like wait what is oh in 90
years wait what oh i was also sleeping it didn't even show
up in my area oh in 90 years oh i was like wait i thought
eclipse happened what makes this one so special i'm so
confused oh not for another 20 years in n a oh i see i see
so like people in n a are just we're just we just don't have
the privilege i see i guess west coast just fuck west coast
i guess fuck west coast i guess all right all right Um, Kaz,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fortnite ReapTail Therapy is back.
Hell yeah, it is.
Many, Foxy, and Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Joe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Petition for the devil to bless Doki Bo.
I don't understand.
If they can bless the sword, why can't they bless the Bo
too?
Like, what?
You have limited blessing powers?
you're literally god like oh i ran out of energy to bless
you now like what the fuck is that you might as well just
fucking bless both if you really want to be to do your
fucking job just fucking give me the power to do the job
like he gets tired like oh yeah but he's not tired of
backseating me no no no god is not tired of that um
uh let's see uh lali thank you the super chat thank you
thank you only a hundred years since toilet paper can be
legally advertised as splinter free thank you the super chat
thank you thank you west great job professional stress oil
therapist thank you the super chat thank you thank you um
chi speaking of solar power did you ever play that old
nintendo game boy game that required to physically be under
the sun irl thank you the super chat Yeah, cheat.
Thank you.
No, most of the Game Boy games I played were, like, Pokemon.
And I remember I played the Pokemon one, the Dragon Ball Z
game, where it was, like, an RPG-esque one.
And then, I really, a lot of the Pokemon, like, a lot of the
Game Boy games I had were...
I'm trying to remember.
I literally only remember the most of the games I remember,
which is Pokemon.
But, like, you know, like, when you're, like...
I don't know if this is like an Asian kid thing or like like
any kid thing But like my mom would buy me these little like
boxes and I just chuck my game cardages in there Like I just
have these little I think they're like I think they're like
IKEA boxes Like those like little IKEA tiny boxes and stuff
And they were like green like they're like neon is s colors
And then like we would just chuck them chuck all the
cardages there in there And then I just like browse through
and try to find the game to play But, um, uh, I don't
remember what game I played, like, what other games I have
other than Pokemon and, uh, Pokemon and that Dragon Ball Z
game, because I play that Dragon Ball Z game for a fucking
ever.
I never played that fucking Dragon Ball Z game for so
fucking long.
Um, so it's, like, embedded into my memory.
Any RPG, the RPG one, it's like, it was like semi-RPG.
I remember
um I don't know I need to like look it up I can't like
remember on top of my head what what it was but I I found
out that like a lot of the game boy games like a lot of the
game boy games like game boy advanced or whatever or just
normal game boy like the cartridges like it has a battery in
there and it can expire I didn't realize that I thought like
you know it's like a CD.
It never dies, except like, I don't know, if it's like super
scratched up or stuff.
But I didn't realize, like, a lot of them have, like, a
little battery built in.
So, like, a lot of the old games are like the same, yeah,
for the save file.
Like, a lot of the old games and stuff, they don't really
work anymore because there's no, the battery, the battery
just dies.
The, yeah, the save games and stuff.
Yeah, it can die down.
Uh, so they expire, yeah, I didn't realize that, so you
might lose your saves soon in a couple of years!
Or replace the battery, they can recharge, or they have to
replace them and recharge it.
Um, I thought it was super interesting, uh, that, like, I
didn't realize there were, like, batteries inside the
cartridges.
Um...
Let's see.
Where was I?
Uh, attack, uh, arcade, boomer, ginger.
Thank you for a super chat thank you thank you sleep holly
fuck oh yeah this one guy was like holy fuck i left out my
meeting are we still looking that was when i had the great
lake adventure
the great fucking lake adventure
we made it though we fucking made it um it was like a one
super chat that i really Where is it?
Where is it?
It was this one super chat I really, really wanted to read,
but I can't.
It was a long one.
But I can't find it anymore.
I saw it, but it went by so fast because I forgot to pull up
the only super chat chat that I missed out.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is?
Does anyone remember the guy's name?
He said he had to do, like, go somewhere.
What was that guy's name?
What color was it?
I don't remember.
Because I remember everybody was like, was like saying
something about it.
No, I don't know.
Guys, your memory is just as bad as mine.
Was it deaf?
Yeah, deafwisher.
That's the guy.
So everybody was like, like deafwisher.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Who's deaf are you wishing for?
Like, I was so confused.
I was like, because I saw the super chat like so fast, so I
didn't see the name.
And then everybody was like wishing deaf for something.
And I was like, bro, what the fuck happened in my chat?
Who the fucking...
Who's deaf do you guys want to wish for?
I'm so confused.
Oh, there you go.
Hey, Doki.
I love watching streams and it reminds you for pushing
forward even when it is incredibly tough.
Couldn't do any of my meps to join the Air Force and just
finish my ASVAB.
What the fuck is ASVAB?
Wish me luck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is that?
The Armed Service Vocational Aptitude Battery.
Do you make that?
What is that?
What is apt for?
Develop abilities and help predict future academic and
occupational success in the military.
Oh!
The fucking Air Force.
You gotta have like...
I'd be able to like, like take in like what's the high
pressure rate.
So like when you're flying a plane really high, you like
don't pass out and stuff.
Oh, it's an IQ test!
What's your IQ?
Oh, so you're smart enough to be in the Air Force.
Can you...
Is that good?
I don't know.
I don't know how smart you have to be in the Air Force.
I guess you need to know physics, right?
Like...
Not all of the Air Force fly planes, though.
Then why do they call the Air Force?
Like...
What's the point?
Then what?
Ground Force?
You might as well be the fucking land force If you're not
all of them, we're gonna fly Yes, I don't know I don't know
if the air force Requires you to be smart I don't know
I'm not in the military Why would I know this information
Like I like how you guys Assume I know how smart You have to
be in the air force and this is american air force i assume
yeah it's in the usd like i'm not american how am i supposed
to know how smart you have to be in america an american air
force i barely know how smart you have to be in the canadian
do we have an army or like hypothetical canadian army like
where majority of us are just the mounties
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good luck, Deathwisher.
If you're still here, you'll have a lot of fun.
I wish I joined the Air Force instead, motherfucker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medi, you have to be smart for that.
Oh my god.
I think the, okay, I don't know.
Okay, I don't know.
This might be a little like, whoa, Doki.
But like, I think it's funny that the army in America has
started to recruit in anime conventions.
I don't know and then they get like cosplay like they hire
like professional cosplayers to stand next to their booth to
like uh like you know to stand next to their booth to
recruit I don't know I just find that fucking hilarious like
they're trying to recruit like we like they're trying to
recruit weeds to the army now and I find that so fucking
funny do you guys know that yeah yeah that's a thing for i
didn't realize no but like i didn't notice that until um
until they started hiring professional cosplayers to like
man the booths like really like beautiful anime girls like
standing next to the booth so like to like try and sign up
some like some like i don't know some weaves to join the
army and i thought i thought it was like pretty funny did
you know like the u.s army has a They're like, they're
targeting everybody.
They're also targeting gamers.
Gamers are also not safe.
Gamers, like, Twitch has an official partner Twitch channel
and where they host, like, tournaments and stuff.
And, like, like, stream, like, stream on Twitch, like, the
arm, like, the soldiers in the, in the U.S.
Army, like, the members in the U.S.
Army, they actually do, like, Twitch streams and try to
host, like, like, tournaments because they once host an
Overwatch tournament.
I remember back then, the U.S.
Army sponsored an Overwatch tournament, like an Overwatch
Invitational, and I remembered it because, like, one of my,
like, one of the teams I was in was like, oh my God, we
should, we should, like, you know, sign up for the U.S.
Army Invitational.
Yeah, they have official teams.
They have actual official, like, FPS teams, too.
It is actually, it is crazy.
They have a Wikipedia.
They sponsor like actual like teams in esports.
Spirit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who's in the Royal Canadian Navy, I can say we do
have an army.
One good thing about our military is that we have better
training than most other militaries, or so they say.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Name them.
Better than who?
Call them out.
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um um
anyway i'm gonna call it here everybody i know this was a
super short super chat reading but then i got like a message
of some work stuff i have to do so i have to call it here
guys i had a little fun zax is done with all you guys i hope
like when things started stabilizing um we could have longer
super chat talks again um after the I'll try my best to
stabilize as fast as like not as fast But like I'll try my
best to one day be stabilized So I don't have to worry about
work stuff after stream Um I guess We're slowly getting back
into it though We're slowly getting back to having like
regular super chat talks Uh super chat readings after
streams Um just takes a little bit slow and steady Uh as
always everybody Say hydrated Posture check and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stayed up for me head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye